madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal après l'annonce d'une nouvelle
épidémie de listériose le gouvernement
espère les premiers résultats de
l'enquêté en milieu de semaine d'ici là
prudence pour les personnes à risque on
ignore tout de l'origine de la bactérie
réaction des consommateurs au kosovo
pour tenter de maintenir l'ordre à
mitrovica elle les forces de la paix
relancées vaste perquisition à la
recherche de caches d'armes des
incidents accompagner cette opération
la victoire éclatante des réformateurs
en iran signe du changement à venir
l'exemple de l'île de kish ancienne
propriété du shah d'iran où les
autorités test un mode de vie à
l'occidentale à pas comptés la 25e
cérémonie des césars une nuit des toiles
pour les vénus quatre récompenses pour
le film de tonie marshall et d'autres
femmes à l'honneur
quant au très beau film de patrice
leconte la fille sur le pont c'est
daniel auteuil qui obtient le césar du
meilleur acteur daniel auteuil qui est
notre invité devant la situation
d'extrême tension au nord du kosovo dans
la ville de mitrovica de théâtre
d'affrontements entre les communautés
serbe et albanaise
la kfor tente depuis ce matin une vaste
opération de désarmement maison par
maison perquisitionnant ici et là pour
débusquer les caches d'armes une
douzaine de serbes auraient été
interpellées alors que les soldats
américains ont été accueillis par des
jets de pierre sur place nos envoyés
spéciaux n ponsinet et gilles jacquier
et la première
les allemands et les américains mènent
des opérations si importante dans la
partie nord de mitrovica
chez les serbes leur présence a soulevé
la colère de la population
les projecteurs
les serbes ont toujours eu le sentiment
que les français leur est plus favorable
que les autres contingents de la force
en flattant ce matin les français de
leurs applaudissements ils cherchent à
induire une vision au sein de la kfor
mais peut-être plus d'uniformes de la
kfor mais dans la tête c'est pas pareil
ils n'ont pas les mêmes sentiments la
population serbe prétend même si les
journalistes si c'est une équipe de télé
qui est prise à partie parce que l'état
le monde s'élance et d'hélicoptères la
kfor a expliqué aux habitants des
quartiers nord de mitrovica le but de
cette opération c'est la plus importante
jamais lancée dans la ville avec 2500
hommes en renfort qu'est ce que vous
lisez
c'est un avertissement pour rendre les
armes
les soldats ont procédé à des fouilles
exhaustive l'immeuble appartement par
appartement
à l'heure où ils sont arrivés dans ce
bâtiment la population c'est forcément
investi de leur action pourtant ils ont
tenté ce dont une kalachnikov g7 serbe
elle affirme qu'ils tout le monde est
armé et nabil al watan en hommage au
père la garde
sovo sésame on nous les a rejoints et
pour cause elles valaient aussi en ont
dans cet immeuble
la prise de fait impressionnant ce
design aux yeux surtout des fusils de
type kalachnikov ak47 des fusils
d'assaut russes et puis des grenades en
parfaite état de consommer mais dans
l'ensemble le bilan est mitigé 14 armes
seulement c'est lié au total et des
termes indigné
l'opération ibach sz poursuivra dans un
climat tant ce que la kfor a voulu
exprimer aujourd'hui à mitrovica c'est
sa détermination et son unité
elle a voulu montrer aux populations
serbes et albanaises qu'il n'y a pas de
différence entre un soldat américain
allemand ou français en iran à huit
personnes dont un enfant ont été tués et
une dizaine d'autres blessés après la
proclamation des résultats des élections
législatives
officiellement pour ce premier tour la
victoire écrasante des réformateurs
près des deux tiers des sièges leur
appartienne désormais la ville d'ys par
la troisième ville du pays est passé à
100 % du côté de cette gauche réformiste
les conservateurs ne peuvent que
reconnaître leur cuisante défaite à
l'évidence l'heure est au changement
dans la direction des affaires de l'état
mais aussi dans la société tout entière
signe des temps à l'avant-garde sans
doute de ces bouleversements à venir
l'exemple de l'île de kish propriété de
l'ex shah d'iran transformer à
l'occidentale par le gouvernement
réformiste du président rami la
république islamiste peut ainsi tester à
petit pas l'ouverture de son économie
mais aussi la libéralisation des moeurs
dans cet îlot à l'abri de la contagion
jean marc et 12 jean françois renaud et
six des morts on ferme hic et il se
passe de drôles de choses dans l'île de
kish en république islamique d'iran
ce parc d'attractions flambant neuf qui
attend le client à 1h30 d'avion de
téhéran a été construit avec des
capitaux privés
et si ce tunnel mène à une caverne d'ali
baba à l'américaine c'est avec la
bénédiction des autorités iraniennes
les 350 francs du billet d'avion le tout
et rend riche et même moins riches les
récupérera grâce osez que 2007 pour les
marchandises des taxes et de ce bazar
ultramoderne de l'une des trois zones
franches où l'iran est une ouverture
sans restriction au capitalisme
occidental
et klich c'est chic ici c'est beaucoup
moins cher et il y a plus de foi dit ces
deux jeunes femmes de téhéran pour
exporter non plus la révolution
islamique mais la perse antique un
véritable empire hôtelier housse
actuellement à quiche pour démontrer que
les capitaux privés font confiance au
président khatami conférence de presse
commune un milliard diar iranien
professionnels de l'hôtellerie aux
canaries au côté du gouverneur le tiche
en millions de dollars
il ya investi attiches qui a financé le
premier mcdo pardon le premier venus
vulgaire iranien peut-être mais pas las
vegas akish le port du foulard est
obligatoire comme danser en public
toujours interdite mais inévitablement
l'ouverture économique entraîne le
premier assouplissement sérieux de la
loi islamique
les jeunes ne peuvent pas passer leur
temps à la mosquée avait dit le
président rate amis parce que le coran
interdit les jeux d'argent ici le
jackpot se paye en jouets en peluche
petit compromis à l'iranienne entre le
bien et le mal
alors on vient attiches pas seulement
pour le charme de son crépuscule
mais pour y goûter un petit air de
liberté introuvables ailleurs dans le
reste de l'iran les orchestres public
reste toujours interdite cette saisie
importante de cocaïne en guadeloupe
quelques 243 kg ont été découverts à
bord d'un cargo chypriote dans le port
de pointe-à-pitre une saisie qui est la
plus importante réalisée par les
services français depuis 91
la drogue était dissimulée à bord de
plusieurs sacs de sport recouverts d'un
produit destiné à dérouter le flair des
chiens des douaniers en france sur les
traces de la listériose ou plus
exactement de la bactérie responsable de
l'épidémie qui a fait je vous le
rappelle cette victime
les consommateurs sont bien obligés de
surveiller le contenu de leur assiette
en attendant milieu de semaine les
premiers résultats de l'enquêté
entreprise par les autorités sanitaires
mais rien n'indique à cette date on
pourra précisément connaître l'origine
de cette épidémie
prudence donc pour les femmes enceintes
et des personnes âgées yasmina farber
diane richard léger malaise chez les
consommateurs à la sortie de ce
supermarché parisien l'alertent à
l'épidémie de listériose est lancée mais
la gamme de produits à risques
charcuteries fromages poissons fumés
reste très vaste difficile d'avaler une
information alarmiste mais trop floue
totalement foireux qui éprouvera connu
comprends rien du tout
on sait tous on sait même pas où ça peut
se trouver comme ans après je trouvais
qu'est ce qu'on risque si on a quelque
chose je sais pas quels sont les
aliments à risque en fait c'est à dire
qu'enfin parce qu'il n'ya plus rien voir
j'ai pas acheté de rillettes en
attendant les résultats scientifiques
les professionnels prennent les devants
comme ici dans cette supérette de
toulouse dans les rayons certains
produits n'ont plus la cote écrit mais
tout un lot de rillettes suite aux
problèmes qu'il ya eu donc je n'ai pas
renouvelé la demande en plus le client
demande demandant pas pour l'instant
j'ai préféré l'arrêter momentanément
pendant ce temps les pouvoirs publics
remettre certaines mesures déjà
annoncées au goût du jour les
professionnels de la filière charcuterie
doivent réduire de 12 jours lors date
limite de consommation
une précaution immédiate qui va limiter
le risque de mauvaise conservation dans
les réfrigérateurs privé mais le client
mérite aussi une information plus
lisibles les personnes qui en plus sont
souvent les plus fragiles et plus âgés
qui voit moins bien ne peuvent pas bien
lire les choses ne comprennent pas bien
la date limite de consommation par
exemple donc si on travaille sur
l'information parce que la listériose
est une très vieille maladie il ya très
longtemps qui en a mais maintenant qu'on
peut la dépister et qu'on peut la
soigner
bon c'est important aussi de pouvoir
l'éviter petits commerçants ou
professionnels de la grande distribution
tout le monde attend le verdict des
enquêteurs dans leur traque de l'aliment
suspect mais en 92 lors d'une grave
épidémie de listériose
il avait fallu de longs mois avant de
trouver le produit contaminé en montagne
alors que se poursuivent pour certaines
zones les vacances d'hiver le risque
d'avalanche c'est pratiquement maximum
le corps d'un randonneur pris dans une
coulée de neige dans l'isère a été
retrouvé hier soir
d'autres skieurs hors piste ont été
emportées en italie du nord un mort deux
blessés
les services de sécurité sont en alerte
pour prévenir tout nouveau risque
d'avalanche comme en témoigne ce
reportage de didier guyot et jean claude
martin déclenchement d'avalanches sur
les crêtes c'est quand vous voulez
sauvayre
7h ce matin la plagne dans le brouillard
quelques 50 pisteurs artificiers sont
partis à l'assaut des cimes de la
station objectif purger au maximum les
couloirs qui surplombe les pistes voilà
qu'il aussi audi prépare une côte avec
lequel on peut passer pour la régler
dans l'enfant en quatre jours il est
tombé 80 cm de neige la plagne le danger
d'avalanche est de 4 sur une échelle qui
comporte cinq niveaux
au petit matin les premiers vacanciers
peuvent s'élancer le vent de ces
derniers jours a créé des plaques à vent
le manteau est instable mais en
déclenchant des coulées de neige de
manière préventive les 200 km de pistes
sont sécurisés 2 kw à 10 59 claude
schneider c'est un peu le monsieur météo
de la station plusieurs fois par semaine
il étudie la résistance et la stabilité
du manteau neigeux température densité
solidité des flocons toutes les couches
sont passés au crible
c'est un commun des normes mille
feuilles composées de ces différentes
couches et chaque couche a ses propres
caractéristiques ses propres type de
grain sa densité
difficile pour autant de prévoir les
avalanches il faut par contre avertir
les skieurs le ski hors piste oui mais
pas n'importe où et le risque zéro
n'existe pas mais entre faire du ski
hors piste à proximité d'une piste dans
des zones boisées dans un certain nombre
d'endroits
c'est aussi faire du ski hors piste dans
des couloirs raides aux abords des
crêtes là où il ya eu beaucoup de vent
et beaucoup d'accumulation de neige et
ben c'est pas possible n'importe quand
sur les alpes le beau temps est annoncé
mais il est quand même conseillé de
rester prudent
pour de nombreux lycées à la rentrée
scolaire se fera demain l'occasion de
nous intéressait ce système d' aide
individualisée mis en place depuis
septembre dernier par l'éducation
nationale tout faire pour éviter l'échec
scolaire et permettre à des élèves en
difficulté de rattraper le niveau pour
l'instant ce système ne concerne que les
classes de seconde
exemple au lycée saint-exupéry de
créteil dans le val-de-marne où se sont
rendus nabila tabouret et abd el djeich
certes elles n'ont pas la bosse des
maths mais ces élèves de seconde plutôt
que de sécher sur le calcul des racines
carrées ont choisi de surmonter leurs
lacunes
tous les mercredis elle participe au
cours des deux individus alizés en
mathématiques
le professeur les reçoit par petits
groupes de 8
chaque élève que ça si revoir des
questions qu'elle n'a pas dit elle a
simulé fait je suis je suis pas adepte
des autres montre vite
donc j'ai besoin de venir ici en plus
pour pouvoir bien comprend l'aide
individualisée a été mise en place à la
rentrée de septembre dernier disque ans
et en mathématiques mais également en
français à raison d'une heure par
semaine
elle ne concerne que les classes de
seconde les élèves qui y participent ont
le plus souvent été choisi par les
professeurs à cause de leurs difficultés
mais les bons élèves sont aussi les
bienvenus l'objectif de ce travail est
d'essayer de régler les problèmes qui
peuvent se poser à des élèves qui ne
réussissent pas très bien et
d'approfondir pour ceux qui réussissent
bien et me confortez justement dans
l'eure dans leur travail
en plus des maths et du français
le lycée saint-exupéry a aussi pu mettre
en place une aide individualisée en
anglais et tout est beau même le jeu
pour amadouer les plus allergiques à la
langue de shakespeare était très saine
elle peut consacrer plus de temps à
chacun des élèves mais je pense apporter
un plus pour tout le monde ça peut
donner
je sais pas une envie de retravailler un
peu ses gains et pas du tout une
punition c'est vraiment une deuxième
chance pour pour continuer en grèce
après plusieurs mois de fonctionnement
le premier bilan de l'aide
individualisée et semble-t-il très
positif l'ensemble des professeurs qui
font des daddy visualiser sont ravis les
élèves sont très contentes qui ont
participé on a même beaucoup d'élèves
qui n'en n'ont pas besoin mais qui
souhaitent de participer d'être
individualisé alors pour l'instant c'est
un bilan très positif
au lycée saint-exupéry la formule semble
tellement plaire qu'elle devrait bientôt
être étendue à d'autres matières comme
les sciences physiques mouvement de
grève air france demain et après demain
à l'appel de certains syndicats de
pilotes la direction pense assurer la
quasi totalité de ses vols moyen
courriers les vols long courrier ne
devrait pas être affectée politique en
marge de l'affairé elf après l'annoncé
du renvoi devant le tribunal
correctionnel de roland dumas françois
hollande a demandé ce soir chez nos
confrères du grand jury rtl le monde que
le conseil constitutionnel se prononce
formellement sur le maintien ou non de
roland dumas à la présidence je vous
propose d'écouter le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
moi je souhaite que le conseil continue
nous dise si monsieur roland dumas est
dans une situation compatible avec
l'état de l'instruction judiciaire
si le conseil qu'on tienne nous répond
que oui que sa mise en congé suffit soit
nous acceptons comme nous le faisons
pour d'autres décisions
le verdict du conseil avec les huit ans
je vous conseille fonctionnaires annonce
formelle mélanger cette question que le
conseil colette se pose formellement
cette action et 10 le droit s'il y a
incompatibilité avec la situation
judiciaire
alors qu' il ya une démission d'office
il n'y a pas d'incompatibilité alors que
le congé elle semble ronger
mais je pense qu'il faut éviter toute
polémique et que la seule façon de
l'éviter c'est précisément que
l'instance qui est habilité
d'autant plus que finalement elle est
concernée et bien disent le droit en
reste ils décèdent de l'ancien maire de
saint pétersbourg à nathalie 7 chaque
qui est mort d'une crise cardiaque la
nuit dernière à l'âge de 63 ans
lady mary tine le président par intérim
rend un vibrant hommage à cette figure
politique vladimir poutine qui fut
l'adjointe de sobczak est la mairie de
saint pétersbourg ce réformateur proche
de michael gorbatchev professeur
d'université avait été élu maire de
saint pétersbourg en 80 ans puis battus
cinq ans plus tard une personnalité
politique qui avait démissionné du parti
communiste peu de temps après boris
eltsine
aux etats unis george bush se refait
surface dans la campagne électorale
après sa victoire hier soir lors de la
primaire de caroline du sud un enjeu
d'importance puisque le gouverneur du
texas candidats républicains avaient été
battus il ya une quinzaine de jours par
son rival le sénateur de l'arizona john
mccain john mccain héros de la guerre du
vietnam les deux hommes sont prêtes à en
découdre ils iront jusqu'au bout
etienne leenhardt le soulagement se
lisait hier soir sur le visage de george
bush junior le fils de l'ancien
président américain se sentait même
pousser des ailes après sa victoire en
caroline du sud
regardez vers la maison blanche
avec moi vous n'y verrez jamais un coup
tordu juste un exemple dont vous pourrez
être fier pour son seul adversaire
direct dans le camp républicain john
mccain l'ancien du vietnam
il s'agissait après cette lourde défaite
de faire bonne figure je félicite george
bush je lui souhaite de bien fêter cette
victoire et puis d'aller se reposer car
il va en avoir besoin mais qui ne
s'attendaient sans doute pas à une telle
défaite après deux semaines de campagne
intense dans cet état très conservateur
et surtout après sa victoire dans la
primaire du new hampshire
car dans cette campagne destinée pour
l'instant dans chaque état a départagé
les candidats au sein d'un même parti
mccain ne peut compter que sur la
spirale des victoires face à un georges
bush junior candidat officiel du parti
républicain doté d'une puissance
financière bien supérieure à celle de
john mackey bouchât désert sans le
renier organisation tout préparé dans
tous les états tous les gens sont place
tout la publicité mais qu'elle doit les
deux d'élections réélection élections
rien de stratégie réelle préparation
jouant le tout pour le tout john mccain
était désir soir à pied d'oeuvre dans
l'état du michigan cette fois car les
commentateurs sont à peu près tous
d'accord sur ce point si john mccain ne
remporte pas la primaire du michigan
après demain il aura perdu pratiquement
toutes ses chances d'entrer un jour à la
maison blanche profession présentatrice
de journal télévisé particularité non
voyantes une expérience unique qui a
débuté les un an et demi pour cette
journaliste de séville un pari réussi un
bel exemple d'intégration loin du
marketing audiovisuel diego garcia
patrick des semis coeur
elle se soucie peu de la lumière des
projecteurs nous rien depuis l'âge de 13
ans ne voit plus le monde qui
l'entourent pourtant elle en parle
présentatrice de journal télévisé non
voyantes sans doute une première
mondiale
lorsqu'elle présente le journal de 13
heures elle est journaliste à part
entière en guise de prompteur quelques
feuilles en braille
alors je me perds je l'apprends parker
c'est au nom de l'intégration et de la
solidarité que la chaîne andalouse canal
2 a donné sa chance à cette jeune
sévillanes dans la rédaction
aucun régime de faveur pour cette
journaliste considéré ici comme les
autres
seule différence sur son bureau quelques
aménagements techniques indispensables
le journal connaît un succès grandissant
depuis sa création il y a un an et demi
un engouement qui n'a pas fait tourner
la tête de nourrir jamais été un but
pour moi je pense que la télé changer
confié la présentation du journal à une
jeune aveugle pour la direction de canal
2 c'était un pari risqué
un choix qu'elle justifie par les seules
qualités professionnelles de nous rien
une intégration qui fait honneur à la
télévision publique
si ce n'était qu'un coup pour faire de
l'audience ça n'aurait jamais marché
depuis un an et demi comme ça a marché a
sévi comme ailleurs en andalousie
l'audience progresse le succès de ce
journal axé sur la culture et la société
a incité la chaîne a doublé son temps
d'antenne il dure aujourd'hui 20 minutes
au début on était un peu surpris et très
vite on voit son journal comme les
autres journaux et puis elle informe
d'une façon claire et efficace
même le ciel ne le revendiquent pas à 25
ans nous rien est devenu un symbole pour
tous ceux qui souffrent des capacités
mais dans les rues de séville c'est une
jeune fille comme les autres au bras de
son fiancé
et lorsqu'elle ne sera plus
présentatrice de journal télévisé s'est
déjà dessinée
son nouveau défi ce sera le reportage
sur le terrain
le
le retour en france 2 laurence de la
ferrière qui atteint il ya dix jours
cette base située quelque part en terre
adélie une région de l'antarctique est
dont une partie n'avait jamais été
foulée une expédition militaire à pied à
ski de 73 jours 3000 kilomètres
parcourus et autant d'embûches après le
découragement cette femme de 42 ans ne
conserve aujourd'hui en tête que les
bons souvenirs
marc maisonneuve le pôle sud
dire que c'est au milieu de nulle part
c'est un 12-2 femise et dire que ceux
qui y viennent sont des conquérants de
l'inutile cpo laurence de la ferrière à
un véritable objectif scientifique
ramasser des poussières des toiles des
micro météorites et des glaçons pour les
analyser ici au pôle sud ce 23 novembre
99 et les seuls à 2008 180 mètres
d'altitude
car le lieu n'est pas aussi plaque il y
parle
cet endroit est sans doute l'un des plus
inhospitaliers du globe - 45
le vent de face 140 kg a traîné pendant
38 jours et 1800 km pour atteindre la
base scientifique française
le dôme c'est ici les chercheurs
français analyse les microparticules les
léonides collectées par laurence de
laterrière mobiliser leur part pour un
jour 20 jours vers dumont d'urville en
terre adélie encore 1200 kilomètres à
parcourir
là elle retrouve celui là guidé par
radio et aider moralement surtout tu
restais avait températures très basses
en moyenne moins 35 et ça a été dur pour
la deuxième partie parce que je
commençais quand même à être fatigués
usés et psychologiquement en plus je
savais que j'allais avoir mon objectif
tant que j'aime j'ai eu plus de mal pour
la deuxième partie que pour la première
en fait en ramassant si poussière les
poils
laurence de laterrière va permettre de
révéler ce qui se cache dans l'ombre du
fleuve de glace et secret vieux de
centaines de milliers d'années en italie
bien évidemment la déception après la
victoire du bateau néo-zélandais lors de
la première régate de la finale de la
coupe de l'america reste que
l'engouement suscité par les victoires
successives de l'équipage de pradhan
n'est pas près de s'éteindre comme le
monde ce reportage à naples d' alexandre
kara et d'emmanuel bec dans la baie de
naples le chaque dimanche
ils sont des centaines de gamins faire
des ronds dans l'eau avec l'espoir un
jour le conquérir les maires
mais depuis quelques semaines le yacht
club de la ville doit faire face à une
avalanche d'adhésion les adolescents
fraîchement convertis à la voile par la
réussite de francesco de angelis
le skipper de luna rossa et angelis
c'est un exemple dans le monde de la
voile tous les jeunes rêvent de faire
comme lui de faire la coupe de l'america
est de devenir un champion de angelis il
est formidable j'espère qu'on va gagner
c'est un grand skipper on rêve tous
d'avoir son niveau au yacht-club de
savoia on a veillé tard la nuit dernière
pour voir le virtuose à l'oeuvre un
écran géant et dans la salle les amis de
dix ans djélis en expert il commente les
régates mais à l'autre bout du monde
les hommes de luna rossa sont à la peine
il sort delà des néo zélandais bien
entraîné et armé d'un bateau extrêmement
performant résultat plus d'une minute de
retard pour les italiens mais rien n'est
perdu puisque c'est le premier bateau a
remporté cinq victoires qui empochera la
coupe de l'america 2000 d'ailleurs en
italie tout le monde veut y croire dans
le parcours de luna rossa a provoqué
dans la péninsule
un formidable engouement 4 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est le record
enregistré par la rai ces pluies alors
que partout les cafés retarder leur
fermeture pour suivre l'épreuve après
roberto baggio et alberto tomba naples
s'est trouvé un nouveau héros suis sûr
qu'on va gagner on est vraiment super
fort on a une grande vie et en plus il
ya le capitaine dire en crise c'est un
napolitain
cette nuit encore ils seront des
millions à veiller avec l'espoir sans
doute
que la lune rousse ramènent la coupe de
l'america en europe après 150 ans
d'absence tennis avec cette belle
victoire de cédric pioline qui a
remporté cet après midi le tournoi de
rotterdam la tête de série numéro 8
s'est imposé en finale face au
britannique tim henman 6-7 6-4 7-6 une
rencontre très serrée entre deux joueurs
résolument offensif à 30 ans cédric
pioline remporté son premier tournoi atp
de la saison et devient même temps le
premier français à s'imposer en finale à
rotterdam et puis tennis toujours le
président de france télévisions marc
tessier a annoncé cet après midi dans
stade 2 le renouvellement du contrat
entre la fédération française de tennis
et france 2 france 3 qui continueront
ainsi de retransmettre le tournoi de
tennis de roland garros jusqu'en 2004
cinéma avec la 25ème cérémonie des
césars une nuit des toiles pour les
vénus beauté de tony marshall quatre
fois récompensé un air de déception pour
le film de patrice leconte la fille sur
le pont pourtant huit fois nominé qui
n'a obtenu qu'un césar celui du meilleur
acteur décerné à daniel auteuil qui est
notre invité mais tout de suite une
évocation de cette soirée avec en reines
d'un jour qui n'en revient toujours pas
la réalisatrice tonie marshall nikon
corp du langlois donc nous avons vu
comment les quatre césars pour battre
son coeur plus fort vénus beauté
meilleur film tony marshall pour venise
buts et meilleur scénario
tonie marshall et meilleure réalisation
et puis meilleur espoir féminin à audrey
tautou les voter bonjour pourquoi c'est
à toi peeling à base d'enzymes en
décembre janvier février
filmé avec humour et tendresse c'est
l'univers des instituts de beauté la
solitude des femmes mais aussi des beaux
portraits d'hommes qui les entoure
après l'euphorie partager avec sa mère
micheline presle c'est la lucidité quand
je disais reine d'un jour hier c'est que
c'est profondément mon sentiment c'est à
dire que après il ya la vraie vie quoi
c'est à dire qu'on retombe dans les
mêmes
même en boîte par rapport à ce qu'on va
faire et financièrement ça peut
peut-être bien sûr non je suis sûr que
je n'aurai pas les mêmes difficultés
pour celui la meilleure actrice est
attribué à karin viard dans les corps
coup de jeune avec cette actrice
bouleversante dans le rôle d'une femme
enceinte en lutte contre le cancer
détresse et détermination pour merci
beaucoup
ces arts de la musique et ses arts de la
photo pour cette magnifique épopée de
eric value
et le césar du meilleur film étranger
est donné à sur la mère de pedro il
accumule les récompenses depuis le
festival de cannes
un moment d'émotion pour les cinéphiles
catherine deneuve lui portera à new york
son césar d'honneur
humour et professionnalisme de ces
journées wever pour remettre le césar du
meilleur acteur
sophie d'une robe de soirée et de
l'angola au gua ces cinq hommes en même
temps les seize heures et être viau et à
dernier autorise dans la 26e édition blu
colmater les brèches quel brèche pas les
siennes vous voyez bien qu'elle ait fait
les pinceaux il était plus tout plan
dans le rôle de gabor le lanceur de
couteaux des cas quand des casseurs
merci beaucoup plus récemment le deuil
bonsoir vous étiez donc en scène
oui j'ai ôté à g t au théâtre quand
pourquoi vous avez appris oui c'est ça
que j'ai justement comme vous l'avez
appris avec le temps en train de jouer
oui j'étais en train de jouer et et avec
donc magny cours où jouent et de une
scène de la chambre bleue et
un garçon en coulisse laurent pour ne
pas le nommer nous faisait des signes
comme ça avec les bras il avait une
statuette d'un oscar dans le main dont
je voulais j'ai compris que c'était que
c'était bien pour mu était plutôt bien
pour moi voilà c'est comme ça je les ai
appris à ce moment là je pense que j'ai
eus j'ai vu une absence j'ai eu un trou
marianne m'a soufflé et nous sommes et
nous avons continué la pièce après quand
nous sommes arrivés au dos elle lui il
ya eu un truc très joli c'est que le
directeur du théâtre daniel darès est
venu annoncer aux spectateurs que
j'avais donc gagner ce césar du meilleur
acteur et il ya 800 personnes qui se
sont levés
c'était magnifique magnifique et gère
des espaces dans les adore vous en
parler à accueillir à m'écouter m'a
franchement je tant que
j'adore sa moelle et les gentils chose
les récompenses les les gentilles mulele
j'adore ça donc le temps ne change ne
fait ne fait rien se dire que les années
ont beau passer je m'émerveille toujours
je suis toujours heureux de voir un dut
de que des gens des gens dans la salle
où que où qu'on me donne les prix ou la
vie passe comme ça comme une espèce
d'opérette magique je trouve ça très
bien j'en parlais bien c'est bien donc
de ne pas bouder votre plaisir
alors je vais vous demander une chose
unique puisque c'est la première fois
qu'on reçoit un acteur qui a donc reçu
un césar et qu'il n'a pas eu le temps ou
l'occasion en tout cas de faire son
discours de remerciement scaffa use est
arrivé trop tard sortant du théâtre sur
la scène et c'était génériques alors
maintenant vous pouvez vous adresser aux
caméras je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce que
vous comptiez dire à la noble assemblée
réunie hier soir écouter alors voilà je
vais pour être tout à fait franc je
n'avais rien prévu pour la simple raison
que depuis des années je suis avec
bonheur de nommer pour pour différents
films et il m'est arrivé de préparer des
choses mais comme j'étais pas j'avais
pas le prix là par superstition je me
suis dit je ne vais rien préparé ma
marche mais ça a marché donc si vous
voulez c'est qu'on s'est donc est-ce que
j'aurais dit j'aurais dit
si vous voulez j'avais des trucs très à
l'époque de par exemple des films de
claude sautet j'avais un truc sur à
propos de claude sautet et puis après
j'avais des trucs à propos de de téchiné
et puis j'ai vu des trucs à propos de
claude berri donc de toute façon je vais
me remercie claude berri parce qu'il
faut toujours remercie claude berri de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive et patrice
comme face à un petit pendu mais il a
bien entendu été justement non si vous
voulez vous je vous demande et je pense
que j'aurais fait un hommage à tous les
claudia beaucoup claude dans le cinéma
mais je pense que j'aurais remercier
claude sautet que je savais c'est ça et
voilà et tous les claude alors au
passage claude lecomte voilà fait que
devant le club de cornes qui se
reconnaîtra évidemment patrice leconte
au passage puisque en effet vous
collectionnez ou en tout cas vous avez
reçu pas mal de trophées palme à cannes
un deuxième césar vous avez déjà eu
césar plus les prix étranger vous les
mettez ou chez vous un jeu léché je
l'aimais chez moi je songe et j'ai
beaucoup déménagé dans ma vie donc si
vous voulez ils sont peu partout ils
sont six ont dû charger ans j'en perds
mais tu faisant retrouver tous ensemble
c'est oui c'est bien vous organiser
on va quand même parler parler du film
je suis un très beau film moi je trouve
que c'est un rôle très dense à sydney
une force rare son rôle de gabor lanceur
de couteaux et un rôle magnifique parce
que en plus si vous voulez sur ce qui
était magnifique dans ce rôle c'est que
il concrétisait une multitude de
fantasmes
il s'était présenté s'est éteint un
personnage qui apportait le rêve qui
apportait le désir qui a porté le le
plaisir est dans un monde dans un monde
réel un peu gris et lui apporter une
espèce de fantaisie violentes comme ça 7
7 et 7 à 2 un de mes plus beaux
personnages oui et puis bon le plaisir
de jouer sans doute avéré bénin et de et
la rencontre
quand ça arrive c'est quelque chose
s'est allié à une rencontre avec un
metteur en scène avec qui on sait que
quelque chose vient de se passer est que
je sais vous avez continué de tourner le
clip sera notre film que vous venez
d'achever moi j'ai été frappé par ce
regard presque magnétique hypnotique que
vous avez transcender presque deux noms
dans ce film avec les jeux bordé de noir
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu tout
le tout votre personnage est-ce que vous
avez des points communs que ce
personnage qui au fond dans la morale de
ce film ça pourrait être de dire que
chacun sa chance faut avoir confiance et
que tout le monde peut trouver un jour
une fille sur un an
oui ou s'ouvrir je sais pas ce que je
voudrais le point commun c'est en tout
cas c'est le même si faire semblant d'y
croire
déjà parce qu'il ya passé au moment où
on fait semblant d'y croire c'est parce
qu'ils croient très bien je sais ça on
aurait plein de questions à vous poser
mais ce sera pour une autre
d'accord un autre film avec la triste
quand louis laurent j'avais 19 avril wii
qui s'appelle de la veuve de
saint-pierre avec juliette binoche merci
daniel bravo
très sincèrement merci c'est la fin de
ce journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres après l'annoncé d'une
nouvelle épidémie de listériose le
gouvernement espère les premiers
résultats des enquêtes en milieu de
semaine d'ici là prudence pour les
personnes à risque on ignore tout de
l'origine de la bactérie réaction des
consommateurs au kosovo pour tenter de
maintenir l'ordre à mitrovica les forces
de la paix relancé une vaste
perquisition à la recherche de caches
d'armes des incidents accompagner cette
opération
dans un instant la météo avec patrice
drevet et puis tout de suite après
football avec la rencontre paris saint
germain à nancy pour les derniers quarts
de finale de la coupe de la ligue c'est
donc en direct sur notre chaîne
00h10 le dernier journal en compagnie de
thierry thulliez demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités en seconde aborde recevra
ségolène royal ministre délégué chargé
d'enseignement scolaire à 13h carl
bessai rachid arhab à 20h vous
retrouverez claude sérillon et puis
comment sauver nos retraites ce sera le
thème de l'émission mots croisés de
m'asseoir présentée par arlette chabot
et à la nuque
c'est alain duhamel je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2